kia ora i'm councillor darren ludlow and  i'm also chair of the southand museum  and art gallery the proposed  redevelopment of the south museum and  art gallery is a project that council  plans to carry out over 37 months  finishing in 2026. the total project  cost  is about 52 and a half million dollars  and of that council is expected to fund  almost 40 million the invercargill city  council is consulting on a redevelopment  project for the south museum and art  gallery  we think it should take 37 months and  come at a cost of about 52 and a half  million dollars  the second option we're consulting on is  should we provide another seven hundred  thousand dollars for helwakitoya  this will mean we can have a greater  turnover of exhibitions  a greater amount of engagement with the  external community  and also more support for the volunteers  who give their time to work here  so what do you think make a submission  on the long-term plan  now  you